now there's some wrestling in our
circuit there's some
you know there's some hot air balloons
out there and i want you to take a peek
at this guy right here tom shigeru
oh yeah and he had this wrestling uh
this promo video that came out a while
back uh
just about a month ago comparing them to
angie baxters and flat earthers yeah
you've also said quote they have
diminished capacity
could you explain what you meant by that
exactly and would you like to take this
moment to apologize
oh no i was i meant that they're stupid
uh they're poor
um they're all beneath me uh
you know they're losers if they want to
come you know maybe clean up my toilet
or whatever
i could spit on them while they're doing
it give them a little taste of the
mystique
hey rick you're so strong you could even
withstand the ankle lock
oh it's true it's damn true mr greg what
about the uh wrestlers themselves some
of them
have reached out to you saying they used
to be fans of yours
now they've been hurt by your remarks
how do you respond to that
mission accomplished get it mr greg
what's up
oh how are you this is my parrot
solstice you know we always enter the
bring together
anybody wants to get the turkey slicer
come come at me man
mr rick you are never down to the count
you are the best there is the best it
was and the best i ever will be
just keep those genes high and tight and
know that you are the excellence of
execution in
think everything you do what they do
wrestlers
yeah it's fake why can't i win a fake
fight
sign me up let's rehearse and then i'll
whoop your fake ass
that's that's what burned me that part
oh yeah did you guys have it out
yeah i went back at him but that just
yeah it's fake
it's it's it's it's not working it's
organized
but it's not fake at all once you get in
the ring you'd
be surprised how not fake how real it is
and uh often like people are here
waiting to kind of teach you a lesson
once in a while because you're bleeding
in the documentary yeah
that was a death match though but even
the backyard match but
you almost there's always something it
just hurts to take those bumps and i had
three fractured ribs when i had to
wrestle rj city and a bunch of stuff
oh man it's a good look with you as a
wrestler
oh i came back at him this is me coming
back and mystic and i went more
old school style oh yeah buddy here
waiting for the racking
i mean obviously it's got no respect for
the business that thompson
rat king a lot of smack being thrown
around by mystic rick saying wrestling
is fake
what are your thoughts on that oh
was it fake when i nabbed the gab
out of that little russian hunter mr
michael robert
was it fake when i broke the spirit of
that little norwegian
smut mannequin mr crystal
was that fake rick was it fake
when i put the dirty you noggie on
little bobby miyagi
what's that fake ricky
the only thing not real here is you
brother yeah you little diet denier
starch addict
gout candidate i bet you can't even
skateboard
that was the personal the great choice
words for the fans i had to get a man i
had to go get him man
so we i came right back at him because
that's the part that hit me i think
there's a certain
element of people out there that don't
understand
when they call it fake how it hits some
people
yeah that's for sure where does that hit
you when they call it fake
oh man you just don't understand how
real it is until you get in there
it really is like it's getting crazier
and crazier i'm not that it's
there's a there's a real beauty like i
wrestle cult cabana as
one of my favorite matches and ethan
page these guys are
super pro so even though they're making
it real
it's uh it still isn't as painful as
some of those
other lessons people teach you you think
you could beat the fat guy that was in
the beginning of this
a girl yeah come on
you think he has what it takes actually
once it gets once he gets into the ring
do you think he could
i mean has he trained probably that's
the thing like no i'm gonna wrestle
anyone we go on a very short limb and
say no he is not
well then it's just it's kind of like
something you usually shouldn't do
like unless somebody's really so
training because
every wrestling match is as good as
the most experienced person in there you
know or the most
you know like the most trained you know
they don't have to have the most
experience but
someone who really gets it can make you
look good one of my best matches was
with jack perry
and jungle boy aw and he's just so
talented that he
made him made me look like i could do
things that nobody had ever
i'd never tried before a canadian
destroyer and the only reason it works
so well is because he's
so great at it i mean it's certain
things you're not really supposed to
talk about or whatever but
right but he's a super talented wrestler
he's
luke perry's son oh is it really yeah
god dang he's damn beautiful dude yeah
he's great he's a movie star this kid
he's
never smoked never drank he's got a
great head on his shoulder he's tough
his nails
he's better looking about easily sixty
percent of the women i've dated
the easily probably he's a good looking
guy even the guy above him right there
yeah lucha soros he's an amazing
wrestler wow he's
good you know i don't know six eight six
ten
but i would love to see you beat the
[ __ ] out of uh mystic rick though
yeah yeah dude do you guys have a little
uh
like a little like promotion or
something
is it does he have a belt or the uh theo
called him out and he never responded
oh really rat king called him out and he
never responded man
we had a belt that started years ago uh
when they have a podcast called the
fighter and the kid
yeah and they had a vote on their
podcast for
best guest or one of the best guests in
the year and that guy got a belt
so once the belt came into it that it
came that's the origin story the belt
and then you know we started taking on
different characters and you know just
you know kind of like most of our fan
base is really a bunch of rats you know
not bad rats but just like
underdogs you know yeah yeah
cheese hunters you know so yeah i feel
it good evening good afternoon
and other times thanks for watching that
video you just saw
i mean it was okay but the next video
you can watch
could be way better what if you watch a
video right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watch this
one